looks like Warzone won't be the only
Battle Royale with the honor of
collaborating with Attack on Titan for
much longer according to two leakers
fortnite is next in line these two are
the most noted names in fortnite info
leaking having broken many big stories
in the past they claim that the secret
skin for fortnite chapter 4 season 2
will be Erin Yeager the main character
of Attack on Titan this is far from
fortnite's first foray into the world of
anime having crossed over with big names
like Dragon Ball my hero Academia and
Naruto while it's not known for sure all
in-game indications point to chapter 4
season 1 ending on March 8th which would
usually mean that season 2 will begin on
March 10th a note on the quest tab
seemed to confirm this stating that a
looping encrypted message reads zero
three one oh two zero two three if
you're looking for another gaming
experience with an anime flavor to it
make sure to check out Hi-Fi rush if you
haven't already I say that knowing there
is a high chance that a lot of you you
already have because the developer Tango
Gameworks took to Twitter to celebrate
the game reaching 2 million players but
even if you happen to be a part of that
2 mil you should still boot the game
back up so you can practice your
gametography and its new photo mode this
new feature is a part of a free update
that went live today this update also
includes various fixes like one for an
issue where the player cannot progress
during the 808 battle in track 12 a bug
where chip slots weren't accurately
being reflected in game if purchased a
certain way and many more but if you
still need an Xbox to check out Hi-Fi
Rush why not try winning the special
edition Mandalorian consoles there is
even a custom grogu Xbox controller and
hoodie for it I mentioned winning it
because Microsoft is not selling these
items to the public but fans can retweet
the Xbox account and use the hashtag
themandalorian Xbox sweepstakes for a
chance at grabbing them but if you don't
have Twitter and I don't blame you or
you just aren't lucky enough to win one
of the those consoles and you're a
Verizon subscriber you can grab a series
s for just one hundred and fifty dollars
that may sound too good to be true but
it's not uncommon for the series s to go
on sale I don't think I've ever seen it
this low though so if you're a
subscriber to Verizon and you need one
grab it before they sell out and Xbox
isn't the only one with new custom
consoles PlayStation has announced a
partnership with basketball Star LeBron
James for new PlayStation 5 accessories
designed by the NBA star himself the
partnership includes a new PlayStation 5
console cover and a dual sense
controller the limited edition pieces
contain accents and wording like quote
nothing is given everything is earned
both the cover and the Dual sense
controller will be available to
pre-order later this year via
PlayStation direct but pricing has not
been announced yet are you gonna try to
get one of these custom consoles and
what's your hype level for that new
season of fortnite let me know in the
comments
thank you